[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to
superhero films are a dime a dozen so
naturally bright burn stands out from
the crowd
in more ways than one this superman
story with a difference tells the tale
of what would happen if a boy born with
incredible abilities
had the power to do whatever he wanted
there's a lot to unpack from the film
and throughout this video i'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie and its ending
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen the film yet and don't want
anything room for yourself then i highly
suggest that you turn off now
without the way i just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
i hope you enjoy it now sit back relax
and let's get into my breakdown of
bright burn
the movie opens on your typical
archetype of the man of steel story
we join an american farm-based couple
that are struggling to have a child
the pair are suddenly thrust into
parenting when a mysterious ship crash
lands on their property
and the movie follows the two as they
attempt to raise their son brandon who
slowly transforms into a predator of
immense power
brandon is fascinated with insects and
his encyclopedic knowledge of all things
creepy crawlies
makes him an outcast at school that is
picked on by pretty much
everyone one night the ship that he
crash lands and starts calling to him
and after visiting it brandon discovers
his incredible abilities
now whilst in the comics clark kent used
the discovery to realize he was there to
help people
brandon goes a bit like ted bundy upon
discovering that his sister is actually
his mother and slowly comes to the
realization that humans are like insects
to him and should kneel at his feet
nice right well no amount of batman is
going to get us
out of this and the film slowly follows
the boy as he develops into a super
villain
where's martha when you need her anyway
what's so relatable about this movie
is that most people will be able to put
themselves in the shoes of brandon
how many people wish that they had
superpowers growing up purely for
revenge purposes
and the character though evil definitely
has a side to him that i could see in
myself
if i was given amazing gifts i'd
basically right
fly over to anyone's house who thumbs
down this video and give him a wedgie
off the window so
no i won't do that i mean a lovely
person i'd help the world
anyway brandon's parents are torn on
their new son's career path as general
zod
with his father being worried about what
he could become whilst his mother wants
to love and nurture him
one night she finds him speaking in
tongues and levitating above his ship
which is when she discovers that the
spacecraft that he came in has the
ability to cut him
which plays heavily into the ending of
the film brandon believes he hears a
voice say take the world from his ship
and he interprets this as meaning to
take over the entire planet
which of course means stopping by at
that girl's house that he likes to
frighten her to death
and kill her mother who won't let her
speak to him great guy
donning a moth mask he assaults her in
the diner and instead of with great
power comes great responsibility
when bad things happen to people it's
for a good reason by the end of the film
brandon has murdered his uncle in a
scene that will leave yours and the
character's jaw on the floor
and his father who by the way is played
phenomenally by david denham of office
fame
he takes brandon in the woods in an
almost of mice and men call back and
unfortunately discovers the hard way
that brandon is bulletproof
with brandon's mother tory played by
elizabeth banks
the only one left that knows the truth
brandon returns to their house to
terrorize her
and the police naturally they make very
little work for him with the character
redecorating the front lawn
and walls with the officer's blood this
is where the film really comes into its
own for me
and i imagine it's every parent's worst
nightmare seeing what their child could
do to them if they had
unlimited power and weren't too
thoughtful of the consequences
remembering that the ship can damage the
character tori travels back to it and
takes a shot of metal
after the two embrace and she convinces
brandon to do good
she tries to stab him however he catches
her arm
blinds her above the clouds before
dropping her to her death
thousands of feet below brandon has one
and all those that now know his secret
are dead
but in order to appear innocent he must
make it look like an accident
after seeing a plane brandon uses this
to crash into his house
and to make it look like his parents
were killed in an accident the credits
of the film then show his rise to power
with the character going on to cause
many
accidents throughout the world as he
slowly rises in prominence
basically you could tie this into the dc
universe and no one would know it
obviously from this we can take that
nobody could stop the character
and the super powers of the world were
powerless to stop him
whether this is what his original
parents wanted is another thing
completely
with the interpretation of takeover
being completely subjective to the
character
what i love about the psychology of
bright burn is that the character is as
much a victim
as he is menace had he been treated
better by society then he would likely
not have acted the way that he did
however because humans viewed him as
just a weak kid
they picked on him and are the ones that
really forced him to take the steps that
he did
this story is as much a tale about how
absolute power corrupts absolutely
as it is about how humans are bad to
each other for some unknown reason
that forces it all to lash out it's a
brilliant movie that's as much a horror
film as it is a comic book one obviously
i'd love to see a sequel to this as it
feels like the first step into a dark
universe
and there's so many ways that you could
take the character whilst the film isn't
perfect and i would have loved for it to
go on longer
if you're looking for someone who's less
clark kent and more
clock i can't finish that sentence
because i don't want to get to monetize
then you'll heavily enjoy bright burn
overall this is an
awesome film and it gets an 8 out of 10.
so
what were your thoughts on brightburn
did you enjoy the movie
and what did you take from its ending
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the finale of game of thrones which
will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you